meine these ist deutschland braucht eine
queen warum die deutschen sind ja eher
ein mutiges völkchen ohne vieler matter
glanz und gloria wirkliche stars haben
den letzten jahren auch nicht
hervorgebracht oder wie entertainer
thomas gottschalk 14 beispiel nach
achter sehr schräg von mir gesagt hat
wir versinken im trash gefeiert werde
nur noch der größte müll von trash tv im
fernsehen über die polnische daraus
entstehen und nicht zu vergessen mit
denen ich sehr auf kriegsfuß stehe aldi
influence und oberflächlichen youtube
wenn man dann auf das platinum
thronjubiläum der queen schaut sehen es
hier gleich auch um bilder teppich da
sieht man ganz genau die bilder berühren
wie sie auf dem balkon steht umgeben von
charles william und kate und auch ihren
enkeln ich finde den deutschen brauchen
selbst auch eine green wir brauchen eine
person in einem zeitalter des egoismus
die mehr darauf schaut was man auch für
andere tun kann und deswegen plädiere
ich heute abend dafür wir brauchen eine
queen und ich bin sehr gespannt wie der
glöckner sieht ja ich glaube mich zur
verfügung also das wäre etwas was ich
gut machen können der repräsentieren und
bisschen glanz bringen aber auch nicht
nur das auch mich um die menschen
kümmern wenn ich mal schauen wie viele
termine alleine prinzessin an jedes jahr
soll bringt wie viel wie viele termine
das königshaus abliefert im ganzen jahr
also da werden altersheime besucht da
werden leute geehrt ich denke immer bei
uns in deutschland was passt ja gut wir
haben einen präsidenten
aber irgendwie sehe ich die termine
nicht hätte ich sehe die nähe nicht zu
den menschen und und das finde ich schon
sehr
bedauerlich und sehr schade gerade in
zeiten des lockdown oder überhaupt in
schwierigen zeiten auch jetzt in leben
wir ja ein sehr schwierigen zeiten da
braucht man ein staatsoberhaupt wie wie
die queen die ja die fifa die menschen
da heißt sie den menschen mut macht die
allein durch erscheint euer erscheinen
das kann auch ein bundespräsident ein
bundespräsident kann wenn sie denn das
ganze auffangen den menschen mut macht
die menschen ja einfach verzaubert und
bei uns wird eigentlich so irgendwie
schon lange nicht mehr verzaubert in
deutschland also der zauber ist weg er
ist zwar auch generell bei den stars
oder würden sie mir da widersprechen für
das genau was für stars wir versinken ja
schon ein wenig im trash sie verehren ja
marlene dietrich habe ich eben ezer
freilos britische rauch also gibt es
solches ist das denn überhaupt noch und
braucht man ja ja das sind jetzt viele
fragen es werden auch in amerika also
man man macht diese stars nicht mehr in
diesem ausmaß aber
mir passiert ja oft dass junge junge
menschen mit 18 also ich hab es ja viele
fans auch so mit sieben jahren aber so
mit 16 18 fotos wollen und dann sagt der
tierfreund oder so was ich so mache
jetzt foto mit dem takt
legende völlig ohne und und die leute
suchen entweder die leute suchen nach
nach glanz die leute suchen nach
vorbildern und das ist das was viele an
wir mögen das ich dass ich ein stil hat
der konsequent ist der extravagant ist
er die wollen alle so aussehen wie ich
aber ich bin authentisch und ich bin
durch geld und und bin für viele ein
vorbild in dem was ich lebe dass ich
mein leben so leben so lehne ich halte
haben wir einen richtigen waren
deutschen stream wir haben wir jemanden
der fundamenten der authentisch ist und
der eine klare linie hat und wenn jemand
eine klare linie hat dann wird er auch
wahrgenommen wird auch entsprechend
wahrgenommen das wort da müsste man da
erst mal interpretieren wir brauchen
mehr persönlichkeiten wir haben keine
persönlichkeiten mehr das fängt an ich
möchte gar nicht sagen wir haben keine
stars aber wir haben keine
persönlichkeiten mehr frau suding haben
wir den in der politik persönlichkeiten
mögliche vorbilder zu denen man
aufschauen kann
das gar nicht auf die politik dafür da
ist dass sie vorbilder oder menschen
kreiert zu dem man aufschauen kann die
haben vor allem den job gute politik zu
machen dass das leben der menschen
vernünftig zu gestalten und es einfacher
und besser zu machen das ist sicherlich
nicht immer gut gegangen in den letzten
jahren und dann ist es nicht gut geht
herausforderungen wir sprechen ja gleich
noch darüber während der kampagne wie
finde ich hat die deutsche politik sehr
versagt hat sich ein kindern versündigt
die haben sehr unter den glocken
gesprengt gleich noch drüber aber wir
haben auch unser grundgesetz komplett
vergessen
das wurde mit füßen getreten also unsere
werte sind mit füßen getreten worden und
das alles nur sage ich jetzt mal wegen
einer pandemie hat man all das was unser
land ausmacht man einfach vergessen und
das macht mir angst und sorge und das
entfremdet mich von meinem land und ich
glaube das geht auch sehr vielen anderen
menschen so sind sie auch entfremdet
vielleicht bei vorbilder fehlen
vielleicht auch wegen dem politics den
hellweg absoluter wir sind dabei einfach
überall im mittelmaß zu versinken wir
sind super gut wenn man über kinder zum
beispiel sprechen an der schule was wird
er heute gelernt in seinem pony - später
nacht ein generell schauen auf die
persönlichkeiten dieses landes ist
absolut wir sind voll geworden wir gehen
keine extra malen wir sind immer fleißig
wenn man tatsächlich sieht werden
ungefähr 45 millionen menschen die
praktisch arbeiten teilnehmen voll und
teilzeit wenn man der gallup studie
trauen mag den index haben 13 millionen
das sind noch mal 130 millionen menschen
die überhaupt noch wert geschaffen in
deutschland und wir gehen nur noch über
reiche reicher reiche waren 0,1 prozent
in deutschland den vermögen von 5,6
millionen und 1 prozent von 1,3
millionen man sich mal anschaut reden
wir über eine gruppe von 80.000 menschen
und wir reden schon über eine
reichensteuer und gehen nicht an die
mittelschicht dran die einfach mehr
leisten könnte aber anstatt dass er
jetzt schon über die extra meile
sprechen die queen zb steht für mich
eigentlich für respekt für demo dafür
weniger egoistisch zu sein wenn sie über
die extra meile sprechen dann verknüpfen
sie eigentlich dass die menschen mehr
egoistisch sein müssten und dabei der
extra meile geht ja nicht darum
juristisch sein musste glücksrad schon
gesagt wir brauchen vorbilder ich glaube
aber wir bräuchten sie in der politik wo
ich hinschaue wenn man sich die
wahlbeteiligung anschaut da sieht man ja
auch da dass die menschen einfach sich
breitgemacht haben versorgt sind das was
da ist lang und eben auch richtig habe
noch niemanden kennengelernt damit 35
stunden finanziell frei geworden ist
herr broder steinmeier oder harald
glöckler als präsident na ja machen sie
es mich nicht so einfach das ist dann
die antwort na ja es gibt dritte möglich
gehört ob die menschen sich entscheiden
sie verlangen wirklich zu viel von mir
also gut ich kandidiere
[Musik]
als premier schon richtig angesprochen
aber wissen sie ich war immer ein
republikaner
und seither steinmeier regiert bin ich
für die einführung der monarchie ich
möchte auch etwas glanz und glamour an
der spitze haben aber eben nicht nur
glanz und glamour es muss auch begründet
sein oder verwurzelt sein und das haut
nicht hin mit allem das bag glöckler man
kann der monarchie und man kann eine
repräsentanz nicht aus dem nichts
schreiber nicht nein nicht war deswegen
das ist so als würden sie
einem einen 17 jährigen oma sagen die
soll sich wieder auf ihrer jugend b sind
nicht wahr und das make-up entsprechend
ändern das wird keine juveniler
schönheit mehr werden und wir haben das
problem überhaupt die personaldecke in
deutschland ist so dünn wissen sie wie
die gegenwärtige regierung anschaue
frage ich mich was haben die vorher
gemacht waren die irgendwie auf spitze
und haben dann die einmalige gelegenheit
bekommen die ränge eins und genau naja
ich meine zum beispiel unsere großartige
verteidigungsministerin vor allem brea
ich habe ein problem mit namen aber ich
glaube sie heißt wirklich so lange
jedenfalls dass die frau die immer mit
ihrem 21-jährigen sohn verreist weil der
irgendwie noch nicht alleine da ein
ticket kauft ja erledigt frage sie haben
ja eine personaldecke wird können noch
nicht mal ein nachfolger für gottschalk
finden und ein land in dem die geissens
schon als stars gelten ist eigentlich
verloren es hat nur noch nicht gemerkt
dass es so im auslauf den berg runter
rollt deswegen so sich jetzt für eine
monarchie wäre ich will und was bei
ihnen gegenüber sie werden allerdings
auch nur meine zweite wahl das problem
ist nur ich weiß nicht mehr die erste
wahl aber die zwei immerhin mehr
immerhin ja ja also pole position auf
alle verlassen sie können sich
vorstellen natürlich ich bitte sie meine
herrschen muss ich noch mal anschauen
glanz und gloria gloria apropos glanz
und gloria vielleicht könnten sie sich
den job teilen mit gloria vom zaun oder
so das wärs wir sind auch dafür nicht
was wärst du hier hat auch einen sinn
für ein präsent an weisheit nahmen die
alten namen mörder und ein bisschen
verrückt ist ja auch aber das gehört
dazu aber nein wir haben wir haben ihn
schon somit wir haben ein langweiler an
der spitze der immer die sätze falsch
betont und er meint durch das setzen von
pausen gedanken tiefe erzeugen zu können
das funktioniert nicht